you talk about treatment for pan and pandas. So pan and pandas is inflammation and damage to the
brain many times after a strap infection, many times after antibiotic use, different types of
infection that can affect the brain. I get to refer you to a video on my website. There's a blog
post. Let me look it up real quick because I think the blog post is called neuro
inflammation. Yeah. So it's called neuro inflammation and microbial priming. Go to our website
cuttersclinic.com. Go to neuro inflammation and you are all inflammation one word and microbial
primate. Just type in neuro. You'll start to see it in the little search bar. And I have about a 30-minute
video that goes over there. There's many different causes to microglial priming. So you have different
cells in your brain. You have your neurons. That's what everybody knows about. Your neurons carry
information. And I mentioned the myelin cheat cells earlier. Well your myelin cheat cells
surround some of those neurons. And that's what makes that speed of conductivity. So when you have
damage to those myelin cheat cells, then it slows that conductivity and we end up having motor
issues of all sorts of problems. But there's another type of cell in your brain called glial cells.
And those are separated in different types of glial cells. Glial is actually
Latin for glue because that's what they thought it was when they first discovered it. Oh that's just
the glue that kind of holds the neurons together. Well that's not true. Just like anything. There's no
wasted things in your body. Glial cells have very distinct functions. There's different types of glial
cells. And the important one about neuro inflammation has to do with the type of glial cells called microglial
cells are your immune function of the brain. And they can get damaged. They can get damaged from
life disease. They can get damaged from strength. They can get damaged from anything that can cross
the blood-brain barrier. Let's just say that. Anything that can cross the blood-brain barrier can
damage microglial cells. Your blood-brain barriers made up of a different type of glial cells called
an astrocyte. And if you're dealing with a child under about three years old,
they don't, their astrocytes are not wrapping their arterial system of the brain. So they basically
do not have a blood-brain barrier. So with a child, things can get cross the blood-brain barrier because
it's not there. With an adult, things get across the blood-brain barrier because some things will pass
and things will damage the blood-brain barrier. So we can have things that damage the blood-brain barrier.
Even traumas are big to damage the blood-brain barrier and big in-damaging
microglial cells. So anything that gets across the blood-brain barrier like a toxin,
that's the bad thing about the injections that are recommended for childhoods and for different
diseases because they contain chemicals that are nanoparticles. So they contain nano-aluminum
and nano-aluminum is, oh, well, that's not so harmful because it's really smoke. It's actually
more harmful because it's in a nano form because it's easily and readily crosses the blood-brain barrier.
It easily and readily damages the microglial cells. So microglial cells get damaged and that's what's
there in what's called a prime condition that's hyper-inflammatory. I could go on for about an hour of
this, but I'm going to refer you to that video because that will really help explain what's going on with
any neural inflammation, whether it's from, and we give it a pand or pandas, or whether it's
from Lyme disease, whether it's from chemo-induced neurotoxicity, and we call it chemo-brain, whether it's
from some chemical toxicity, or whether it's from post-compulsive disorders. It's all the same,
you're dealing with microglial primates. So there's really two levels of danger when you talk about
brain inflammation. You can get microglial primate, which could be bad enough as it is, could cause
all sorts of dysfunction, and you're going to have the dysfunction in where in the brain that is
happening. So if you have more microglial primate in the prefrontal cortex, that's this part of the
brain. That's your executive function of the brain. Then you're going to have dysfunction in memory,
understanding, and executive function, you're going to have cognitive disorders. If it's in the
frontal motor cortex, which is a little farther back in the brain, then you can have motor issues,
and some tremor issues, and motor conductivity issues, and muscle-physiculation issues.
If it's in the pride alone, then you're going to have more sensory issues. So you're going to have
pain that is in my lefty today, and that doesn't hurt, but it's my right ankle is hurting. I can't
figure out, and there's nothing wrong with my lefty or my right ankle that it could travel around because
the inflammation in the microglial primate is in that part of the brain, in the pride alone, where that
sensory input comes back in. So if it's in the temporal lobe, you're going to have hearing issues,
and balance issues, and vestibular issues. If it's in the cerebellum, you're definitely going
to have vestibular issues, balance issues. If it's in the back of the brain, you could have vision
issues. So it depends on where that is taking place. Pants and pandas is the same thing. If it's in
the midbrain, you could have all sorts of autonomic issues. So this damage could take place anywhere
in the brain, so it could give a collection of symptoms based upon where that damage exists.
I said there's really two levels of damage that is caused from neural inflammation. One is the
microglial primate, which I said is bad enough, but the second one is even worse. That's when we end
up developing antibodies to neural tissue. So there is a test for that. You could do Cyrex array
7X, so you can see if you have antibodies to any neural tissue, I said. Tested somebody
in the day, and they have neural antibodies to myelin. She sells, that's just one thing that
that tests for. Well, now you know you're going to have destruction of myelin. She sells every time
you stimulate an immune system reaction for anything. I said, you even get a cold in your immune system
optics. You're going to have more destruction of those myelin. She sells. You're going to have more
demyelidation taking place. Again, that could be anywhere where that is in the brain. It's going to be
on myelin. She sells not every, not every neuron is myelinated, but all your motor neurons are going
to be myelinated and you're going to definitely have motor neuron issues. So the danger to that is,
what I already stated, if I have antibodies to neural tissue every time I stimulate an immune system,
reaction for anything, it's going to get worse. And one of the chief errors in care from a natural
perspective is doctors will say, well, it's from this infection. So it only makes sense to treat that
infection. We need to give urinals and things that are going to stimulate an immune system to kill that
infection. That's a really wrong thing to do. So again, you'll find a lot more information on the
autoimmune course on that. It's pretty cheap to do that. I recommend spend the 50 bucks and start
watching some of those videos and work your way through that course. There's a lot on there
that I add stuff on there literally, weekly. So even if you're on module 4, go back to the first
three modules because I probably added a bunch of stuff. So every time I'm learning new stuff, I put
it on that course. Anything that has to do with autoimmune disease. So I'll make a video about it or
something like that. I'll put it on that course. So dealing with pans and pans is dealing with
inflammation of the brain. It could be just microglial primate that is the cause of that person's
symptoms and that would be bad enough. Or you could have neural antibodies that have been created.
And you can test for that. Can't test for microglial primate. It's mainly just
side-in-syptomated person is happy. And still, dealing with that, you still have to deal with triggers.
So super important. But in that video, I explained a lot of it.